hey everyone scott moviemance here
for collider and one thing that i've
been raving about
on collider videos for your
consideration
is the film first cow so that's why
i am very very excited to conduct this
interview
with orion lee about first cal now the
film
tells a story of two opportunists
in 1820s oregon to take advantage of
their take
on the american dream and orion lee
you know i would love to hear your take
on the screenplay
when you read it for the very first time
at the end of it i was puzzled because i
was like
why am i weeping and
because as i went through the
you know the script i you know i didn't
feel there was any particular
emotion coming up it wasn't a
particularly emotional script
um but then at the end i read that sort
of last line and i and i went and i was
like
wow what what's happened here and um
and i think what what happened is as i
reflect upon it more i think
what it is is kelly's managed to
create a structure
which is like friendship and like
friendship you know it doesn't start off
with passionate fireworks
it's just hey how are you doing oh
what's your name oh yeah okay cool
um and then you know you have a chat and
then
you might see the other guy again or go
again and then
you know you say have another chat and
then
years go by and suddenly if that
friendship
was ever gone you would feel the loss
and and the movie kind of does that too
and the script kind of does that too
you know i got to tell you so this
relationship between king lewd your
character
and cookie played by john magaro so both
of these guys
like have seemingly nothing
in common but they really connect
and they do it in a way that is
absolutely authentic and genuine and
believable
first of all why do you think these two
guys connect
and how did you and john connect to
capture that chemistry
um long question good question
so the first part is uh
when i was reading script and i was
discussing the character with kelly
um my initial when on reading the script
i thought these were two
soulmates these were two people who are
very similar who
had the same similar sort of background
and a similar sort of attitude to life
and so
they became friends when i
had a chat to kelly though she was like
no they're
they're complete opposites you know and
i i struggle with that because i believe
similarities
connect rather than opposites and
and you know you know kingdom is very
fresh and charming and then like
comment and i was like oh wow how do i
but in that sort of puzzle
i was like struggling over it i came to
this kind of idea for the back story of
kangloo
which basically i'm gonna
cut it on basically say that when he was
younger
he was he was pretty much um
cookies character very quiet very
reserved
and then i mean this was really his
child
and then and then he had to leave
well he didn't have to leave but he left
china
sailed around the world and in that
process
he had to learn how to become very
social very
uh sort of personable and hey how are
you doing and have a chat with different
languages
and as a kind of survival mechanism
and then it became him like when you do
something over and over and over and
over and over again
you become that new person
and but deep down
actually he is the quiet reserved person
that
that cookie is and so when they meet
it's not necessarily a
a you know they don't necessarily think
that they're soul mates so that they're
but something clicks in them deep down
uh that they have a similar
sort of background or philosophy um
in terms of more practically acting-wise
with john
i i think
you know we didn't ever sit down and go
oh how are we going to
like portray this relationship how are
we going to connect as a
as friends um we just met each other it
looks like
like a friendship like i've just said
you know just met each other saying hi
how are you doing
yeah and then we went on the camp
together
for three days learning about um you
know the period
and how how that how to cook how to
make twine how to make a fire how to
flint um
stone and but even then we never
chatted about oh this is how we're gonna
do it
and again i've reflected upon that and i
think
what it is perhaps was
to actors
listening to each other like really
listening
because we didn't talk about what we
were going to do we had to
sit in the scene and listen to each
other
um and see what the other person was
offering up and then
throw it you know throw the ball back
and forth
and and
it's actually really rare for that to
happen i agree with you
it is it is rare and that was one of the
things
when i saw this movie for the first time
i was really struck
i was really affected by that connection
but i was also really affected by just
how
how authentic and lived in
kelly reichert's depiction of of the
1820s felt
like it really felt like you were in it
and i didn't even realize that you
had sort of done like a boot camp to
capture all of that
so tell us more about that um
that boot camp was um
yeah we had a
guy guiding us and he sort of showed us
um
lots of different things about trappings
you know my character
trapped some uh
small animals for food and um
we learned uh about making the fire with
uh with flint and stone uh
when we were on set doing it i was like
slowly getting the the tinder and just
and suddenly it flared up and it was
like whoa
and then chucked it into the fire where
the wood was
um but that seed
that that that didn't catch they didn't
actually
uh use that scene in the film
and yeah and how to make twine uh out of
like um you know sort of a plant stalk
and and things like that um it was just
really useful
and and then you know the rest of it is
the genius of
you know the costume and design
department and
makeup department and everybody really
the whole team was so
fantastic um to work with to to be with
that sort of familial uh friendly set
was amazing to be on um
yeah really really good well this is
like the first
lead role you've ever had in a movie so
what were those challenges like for you
like how did you
like sort of psych yourself up to be
like
okay this is a big step for me as an
actor
yeah um you know for any actors that are
out there
listening to this um
you know i was nervous i had done lead
roles in
stage before but this was uh
such a big thing and to work with kelly
as well um
and really i i
sort of took the approach that i was
just gonna go scene by scene
and um because we all
actors all know how to do scenes we
we've done
scenes for you know to audition we go to
drama school we've done scenes in drama
school we've done
auditions which are scenes you know just
you know short scenes and
and then you know we've probably done
quite a bit of work already
as short scenes in films and television
and so on and
and so i took that approach i'm
only going to think about the whole
movie as just one
scene and then one scene and then one
scene and then
and and so all i did was exactly what
i've done
for everything i've already done which
is just work on a scene
um and also i wanted that sort of
intensity when you just work on the
scene on the short period and
and you want that that sort of yeah that
intensity going into that
that time period as opposed to the same
intensity split over
you know in this period of this whole
movie um
[Music]
so that helped a lot and
[Music]
yeah i that's the way i thought about it
the
other interesting thing which came up
though was
i was thinking about the arc um because
i was worried if i was working my scene
would there be a character up
and the interesting thing about that is
one you can as an actor you can leave
that to
the story and you can leave that to the
audience
because they will create the art for you
and the story will create the art for
you
and i really believe as a person
you have many different things at many
different times
depending on the situation or in this
case the scene
so you can you don't have to think okay
i'm going to
be continually i don't know nice
continually this or or so that there's a
consistency to the character no i don't
think you do
i think you like a like a person in life
you do many different things and then
the the audience gets to say you know
what
this is this person this is the
character so the interesting thing is
like
you know you've worked on such big films
like star wars the last jedi
skyfall uh what's it like going
even though your role obviously is is a
lead in first cal
but going from such a big production
where i'm guessing
the craft services on skyfall
was was was bigger than the entire
budget for first cow
um first of all cross services were
fantastic on first car
so you know no complaints are at all um
the main thing
is is um the amount of time i guess you
get with the director
um although you know when you're on the
set
you know every director worked it with
has been
very generous with their sort of time um
but the main
i guess the main thing is yeah that
access to the director
uh sort of pre it and then during it
and because it is really the director's
vision
and that's you know the movie is kelly
it's kelly's vision and
um part of my job is to to
you know to to help create that and
yeah i think i would say
that's one of the main things in terms
of budget
you know we had all we needed in the
forest the oregon first you know the
oregon
landscape um you know
so and then in terms of as an actor
i mean those sets and those costumes and
those props
uh the whole all those departments were
so fantastic
to work with so you
you end up being in the time and in the
space
yeah so the end of this film don't want
to spoil it
for those who haven't seen it yet but
please make sure you do see it it's on
demand
so just overall like what's your take on
a film
that really leaves it open to
interpretation
that leaves it up to you the movie
watcher
to draw your own conclusions like this
movie does
oh gosh
that's a wonderful thing about kelly's
work is it
you know to me it is like like art like
um
a work of art which you you you the
audience get to participate in and to
decide what
what it is um
i as an actor have to have a very
specific idea
about what i'm doing and what
it is that i'm doing and i did
i'm hesitating because i'm like i'm like
okay i don't want to say
it because i want the audience to have
their own decision about what's going
through
[Music]
my character's mind in their last
moments and
you know given what the film has
happened so so i'm not going to say it
uh if anybody wants to ask me they can
um
[Music]
and yeah it is
it is kelly's work of art and she
invites the audience
to come in and be a part of it
and to have their own sort of
interpretation their own say of what
it is that they're watching well last
question i have for you orion and say
because you were this was such a again i
i just have talked about this movie so
much here on collider and i
i'm so happy to be talking to you about
it and just i would love to know
your your growth your evolution
as an actor from before you made this
movie
to after shooting rapt how do you feel
like you grew as an actor
working with kelly
i think one of the main things is um
[Music]
yeah i really believe uh what's the term
that's going around
no a-hole no a-hole policy
[Laughter]
um you know calios is such
a a wonderful director to work with
um in the process of of creating the
character
of king lou and cookie we both kind of
became
a little bit towards that and
and so my me as an actor i
i you know ask tons of questions and be
like hey how are you doing
and then and cookie you know and john
magara
was very quiet didn't ask a lot of
questions and
but you know kelly adapted uh sort of
to to us you know to handling us
differently
um because we were both you know moving
towards the characters
um and sort of that flexibility and also
that trust
in the director to who's so good that
they're
you know they're they're watching
everything
and they'll steer you if they need to
and yet you know she leaves a lot of
things just open
to you to do as an actor
and so you can do your job and
so that and that thing until i just
mentioned about the arc
you know and i always thought oh
character art character but actually
you don't need to you can just
concentrate on the scenes
and then finally you know the thing is i
just feel so blessed
to have been you know just part of this
project
um and you know just working on that set
and it's
you know it's just going to be a
highlight throughout
my life well i want to thank you so much
for joining us here on collider to talk
about first cal
and everyone watching please make sure
if you've already seen the movie watch
it again i'm telling you it's even
better the second time around
first cow is on demand it's on home
entertainment
orion lee thank you so much for this
amazing interview and please continue to
stay safe
and promise me that the next time i see
you it'll be in person
okay thank you for being a great
interviewer
thank you so much have a great one